es gibt hier einen stand mit
verschiedenen norwegischen gerüchen
wir sind sehr spezielle dabei unter
anderem tod der großmutter
kurz danach verstören bin ich gerade auf
der buchmesse angelangt hier wird noch
aufgebaut so richtig was los ist noch
nicht aber es hat gehört der gastland
pavillon norwegen ist schon offen und
den schauen wir uns jetzt mal an
also mich interessiert warum norwegische
literatur in deutschland gerade so
erfolgreich ist und vielleicht klappt es
ja sogar dass ich noch ein paar wörter
norwegisch sterne gleich
[Musik]
also wenn man sich die norwegische
literaturlandschaft zur antwort ist es
erstaunlich festzustellen was der staat
alles so tut um seine autoren und die
literatur zu fördern
ln warum ist literatur so wichtig für
die norweger
ich glaube nun in norwegen ist ganz
wichtig weil viele norweger auch sehr
viel lesen will ist im durchschnitt 15
bücher pro jahr was sehr hohes anzahl
ist noch sind sie sehr stolz und wir
wollen unsere geschichten teilen
und was tut der staat alles so dafür um
die leseförderung zu unterstützen
da gibt es mehrere maßnahmen wir haben
beispielsweise einen kulturrat die
kaufen jährlich 750 exemplare von von
belletristik büchern ein
und das wird für alle bibliotheken in
norwegen ausgeteilt das heißt es gibt
immer die aktuellsten bücher in wirklich
jeder ecke kommen vom land
und da gibt es dieses neue projekt der
nationalbibliothek wie das abgelaufen
also alle bücher die vor 2000 erschienen
sind werden da in der nationalbibliothek
eingescannt und die sind dann kostenlos
abrufbar auf ihrer homepage
also wenn ich jetzt auf der buchmesse
ein bisschen norweger sprechen will und
wir haben ein paar norwegen ins gespräch
kommen und sagen möchte ich interessiere
mich sehr für die norwegische literatur
was muss ich da sagen da muss ich sagen
ja wenn die interessenten steht ja wilde
interessentin wilde wilde wilde inter
der sap in ost literatur wir jetzt
gerade bei klaus kathan gelangt die
norwegische literatur ist in deutschland
ja sehr erfolgreich was gibt's ja noch
für beispiele
es gibt natürlich viele ich glaube mit
der modernen gegenwärtigen literatur hat
es angefangen in den 90ern mit just en
garde mit sophies welt neulich natürlich
die mall und mit die geschichte der
bienen
ich weiß auch dass das meeting dieses
jahr kam die die glocke im see die alle
große erfolge sind aber so ganz mit den
schweden mithalten können sie noch nicht
oder
das würde ich nicht sagen ich denke die
der schwedische erfolg ist ja riesengroß
april hat ist vor allem sind vor allem
krimis während es gibt auch natürlich
erfolg mal erfolgreiche innovatoren vor
allem municipal habe ich denke anders
als schweden es die noris die
vielfältigkeit der literatur was erhofft
sich der norwegen jetzt von diesem gast
auftritt auf der buchmesse vor allem
dass die deutschen leser neue autoren
neuer erlebnisse
neue bücher entdecken
[Musik]
als besonders spektakulär ist dieses
dieser auftritt hier von norwegen im
pavillon nicht das muss man zugeben vor
allem wenn man es vergleicht mit dem was
letztes jahr georgien aufgeboten hat
aber vielleicht passt es ja auch so ein
bisschen zur identität und zur lebensart
der norweger bescheiden und irgendwie
auch gemütlich ich habe jedenfalls genug
inspiration für neue literatur aus
norwegen bekommen
[Musik]